hello everyone
and welcome to this webcast regarding
advantage of digital pcr and its
application
the power of petitioning my name is
daniel zlergren and i'm the marketing
and the development manager
for digital pcr in emea
in europe for kaiju
my background is i have six years of
experience with digital pcr
and i have been working with kaijen
since two years back
just to start this introduction first of
all
the system i'm going to present to you
and also some basic of the techniques
it's intended for research use only
if we look for the agenda we will start
with a slightly slight introduction
of the basics and principles of the
digital pcr
after that we will follow with the
change and let's say a difference
between the different
pcr methods we will continue
on with the digital pcr system
technology and specifications
from kaiju we will continue with the
power of petitioning and the enrichment
effect and this is
actually everything behind the
digital pcr we will continue with
applications
tips and tricks and the hallmarks of pcr
and then after that question
so let's start so first of all
when it comes to kaiju the cajun
is a company that has a great expertise
in sample preparation
and also sequencing library prep and pcr
and now since one year back we acquired
the digital pcr technology
from formulatrix and the constellation
system
that we now have renamed to chi acuity
so what is digital pcr
it's for some consider as the third
generation of pcrs
so what does that mean well if we go
back
to 1983 when caramelis actually invented
pcr
what we did in 1983 was that we run our
product we created primers
and an amplicon we did the pcr we ran it
nhl and we stained it with a
dna binding diet like ethidium bromide
and we take a look at it
and hopefully we had our product that is
called
endpoint pcr and this is very important
that you know that this is an endpoint
pcr it just gives you a yes or no answer
so in basic principles this is a digital
pcr
but in a very bad resolution
the second generation of a pcr was when
we
did uh advance the pcr into real-time
pcr
and then we started to use
intercollecting dyes
or hybridization probes or hydrolysis
probes or
molecular beacons or scorpion probes to
actually see what happens after
each cycle this is very important
because
real-time pcr gives us relative
quantification
this means that we actually need
something
to compare against we also use standard
curves
we rely on efficiency because we need to
know that
every cycle has been amplified or
duplicated
perfectly to 100 percent
many people now when we switch to
digital pcr
digital pcr is still and this is very
important an endpoint
measurement we are using
the chemistry for qpcr and this is why
many people are doing a very common
mistake
thinking that digital pcr is based on
efficiency which is
not it's an endpoint measurement but
because we are
using the intercollecting dice or the
chemistry for real time pcr
we can actually do the endpoints
measurement or what we did in a gel back
in 1983
now in 2020 in a much higher resolution
but it's an endpoint measurement means
it's not based on efficiency
and of course since it's a yes or no
answer it's either positive or it's
negative it's nothing in between and it
gives us
absolute quantification it follows also
the normal pcr setup so we actually have
a bulk
sample which we actually have our sample
our template where we actually put in
a master mix and our primers which we
are specific for the sequence we are
looking for
the only difference we are not going to
performing the pcr
in a bulk we actually do that in
petitions
so we actually partitioning the sample
to actually get an enrichment fact and
this is what this
presentation is all about i will come
back to that later
after the petitioning is done then you
do an endpoint pcr
and then we'll take a look at the
outcome
the result which is absolute
quantification
so when we take a look at the dpcr
principles
every digital pcr platform is using
poisson
statistics and the law of random
distribution
and we are doing that statistically also
by
uh measuring this in the nineteen
conference interval so what does this
mean
it means that for a number of certain
molecules that are randomly distributed
into these partitions
we have uh some
space that we can work within
but of course it also sets some
limitations
and some of the these limitations is
actually that we have
let's say a goldilocks zone even for
digital pcr
if you will refer to the goldilocks zone
uh where we are in um
in the qpcr that means that we will we
want to
uh to aim to be let's say not in the
upper end of the standard curve in the
qpcr
and not in the lower end we want to be
somewhere in the middle
so we know that our assay actually works
this is a little bit the same thing we
want to
not have too few molecules because then
we
perhaps cannot trust if there are false
positive or not
this can be checked of course but we
also don't want to get to the other side
where we have an oversteer iteration
because since it's part of statistics
we also go by this uh
very simple formula where we have target
copies per partition
which is the minus logarithmic of one
minus p
and basically that means the fraction of
negatives
and positives so we actually need to
have
both positive and negatives to get the
concentration and this is very important
so the systems normally and what we have
at cartoon is
about five orders of magnitude that
means from one positive
molecule to let's say 150 000
something amplified targets
so if we look at the different the pcr
method so what is the major difference
so
both pcr and qpcr is running bulk
and as i already mentioned in
digital pcr we do partitioning and here
is where
companies or do it differently
so they're on a different number of
petitions
in different number in different vendors
machines
and i will explain what that means to
you as well when
when it comes to the number of petitions
we will have two
sets of plates we are doing our
petitioning on plates which one is
actually 8500 petitions and the other
one is 26
000 petitions
when we look at the offering the kai
acuity systems from
kaijin here you see that we have
actually three
formats we have a
two smaller system which you actually
have five target multiplexing
and two target multiplexing the other
two it has a four plate system where it
can run
four plates simultaneously and the other
one is actually
an eight plate system which can run a
plate cemetery
simultaneously both our plates fit on
all systems
the only difference in between them is
the throughput that we have
and nothing else we run our first plate
within two hours and we can actually
run up to all four plates within less
than six hours
and in this one which has two qp two pcr
machines inside
can actually run all eight within six
hours
so if we look at how our plates are
built
so we are doing our partitioning inside
our wells
so we have an input well which is
actually connected to
a microfluidics and in these
microfluidics we have some nano
compartments
this is a grid which actually are
connected to each other
at this stage they also end up in an air
vent because we need that to be able to
prime
the the well with our sample
so so if we go into what the benefits of
petitioning is actually
actually is so if we look at a real-time
pcr when you we have every
something that are exponential so
basically
the the light emitted is actually
uh based on the concentration in the
normal
uh real-time pcr so the more
concentration we have the more light we
have and also the stronger these
uh ct values or cq values
is they're coming up very early in the
qpcr if you have a lot of product
when we do this partitioning so the
petitioning
is different here we either have a
signal or we don't have a signal
so it's because we either have
an amplify amplification over a target
or we don't so
this random distribution is actually
making this
enrichment effect taking place but
mark my words just because we have a
higher precision to amplify our target
doesn't necessarily
mean that this is more sensitive and
than a qpcr
or a standard pcr because this are still
a pcr technology which means we are
bound to the same principles it means
we can amplify one target molecule but
so can a qpcr
so can uh endpoint pcr the
problem or let's say what the benefit is
with this partitioning
is that by partitioning we increase the
chance of
finding this molecule which is rare
and also therefore we are actually in a
very good way
um
have more precision and this is this is
very crucial
so the benefits of partitioning so
in this example that we have here we
have two conditions the first one
is the 16 microliter uh reaction a bulk
reaction
and in this 60 microliter sample we have
two molecules inside
so the effective concentration in the
bulk sample is now we have
one molecule in eight microliter sample
so if we take this pure sample with only
those molecules and partitioning it in
one magnitude partition in this
particular
sample or example
you will see that these two molecules
randomly er
distributes out to these partitions and
of course
since we have two they will end up in
each
partition so they will not end up in the
same position that could
potentially happen but this is very
unlikely
due to the statistics behind it
so now we have an effective
concentration of one molecule
in one microliter so that means we
effectively we
increase the concentration of this
molecule in this particular case
by eight times so if we take this
same setup i mean in this pure setup
these two molecules will probably be
found by real-time pcr well and will
come up at
let's say cq of 38 or 37 something
because they have no competition it's
very pure
but they will be likely be found
but in the next example here when we are
to the right when we have these two
molecules
surrounded by competitive molecule this
can be two
mutation it can be virus it can be
pathogens
it can be anything that we are looking
for but this
surrounding uh molecules or in a bit
inhibitors will prevent us to find these
two molecules
inside this tube with a real-time pcr
but since we're doing this partitioning
all these molecules competitive
molecules inhibit
inhibitors and anything that can
interrupt us to amplify our target will
randomly distribute
so let's say we have two molecules here
or let's say we have one in
one thousand or one in two thousand of
the mutant
compared to wild type in this bulk
sample you will never find it
but since we do this partitioning now
instead of being one in one thousand
these molecules can be one
in two or by itself or one in three one
in four or one one and five
and we will always amplify this molecule
now because there
is less competition less inhibition
inside these petitionings partitions
so this just means that we have
increased our chance
of getting the molecule amplified
the only problem we have now is actually
to get the molecule inside
the tube
this is what we are going to address in
this picture so
the poisson total error bar contains on
two
error bars or two parts of the error
bars is actually one which is
partitioning error
the petitioning error is actually
limited by the number of petitions or
the number of petitions that you
actually can use
so as i mentioned earlier in this
presentation
uh i talked about this that there are
vendors that has different number of
petitions so we have two different
one it is 8500 and one is 26
000 petitions so they have different
partitioning error because if you can
load less
in the 8500 because that will be
oversaturated much faster than the 26k
and that is what this partitioning error
actually stands for
so the as the normal concentration
actually
increased that means the number of
amplified targets
per petition is increasing and
eventually you will overstrike the rate
overseas rate the
the the well then you see that this uh
partitioning error actually goes up
so if you look at this this is just two
examples by
where we have twenty thousand petitions
and one million petitions so the one
million petitions to
the right you can see that it's the
petitioning area is
very very very low so it's very low
because we have
a lot of petitions so we can load a lot
we can actually have a very abundant
target
without saturated the system
but eventually if we just load load load
load load
we will eventually saturate even
the 1 million petition so the
partitioning error is
limited by the number of petitions that
we
can actually use
and to contradict that we have another
thing
called sub sampling error and this is
what i
addressed in my earlier slide when i
mentioned that
you need to get the molecule inside the
tube
for us to be able to find it and to
amplify
it it's one thing that we can detect it
but we also need it to get
into this tube and this sub sampling
area is what it's all about
so subsampling error actually sets the
limit of detection
that means that if for instance you're
taking a blood sample from me
five milliliters of blood in my volume
which i have which is seven liters of
blood and of course if you have a rare
mutation
that you're looking for inside my body
the
the chance of you actually missing it
when you just take five milliliters of
blood
out of seven liters is quite big so that
is one what's called subsampling so to
really be able to be sure to get
that molecule from me into the tube you
need to take multiple samples for me
to be able to actually get let's say one
in ten thousand or one
million uh for instance
into the tube so that is actually what
sub sampling is all about
so as you can see here the number of the
more dna we put in the more
copies per partitions we have the less
sub sampling error we have so that means
the more dna we screen
the lower limit of detection the lesser
sub sampling error we get
and as you can see on the right when we
have one
million and we just add our dna
the sub sampling error basically goes to
zero
so that means that the partitioning
error and the sub sub bring area is
somewhat contradictory to each other
but this is statistics but this is for
all
uh digital pcr platforms out there using
poisson
statistics these are rules that you
cannot
ignore
if we go to applications tips and tricks
and hallmarks of pcr so what is the
applications normally used for digital
pcr yeah
of course mutation detection is
something that you
immediately think about because of
course this is one of the major things
but i would perhaps say that mutation
detection yes but
more like rarely event detection because
when you have something rare that you
are looking for and that can be
anything basically it can be a virus
it can you can look for invasive species
like environmental dna or ancient dna
something that you just can't find with
a normal standard qpcr
or a normal standard endpoint pcr today
then of course as you have seen with
this petitioning
uh possibilities and the amount of load
a lot of dna
and you can go this low limit of
detection
of course mutation detection is one of
the things that are
like highest on the on on the chart
copy number variation is also one of
them and
the this is because you can see very
small differences
um uh in i mean you have
a precision or plus minus 10 percent i
will come back to that
but that means you can actually see
differences in higher copy number
and this is something you cannot do in a
normal qpcr
so what that means is that you can see a
difference of copy number of 10
and copy number of 11. and this is
something you cannot do
with the qpcr when we talk about gene
expression
this is actually quite not so
straightforward as many things when it
comes
to digital pcr because
normally in in gene expression you have
cdna and cdna you have very abundant
uh you have quite a lot of cdna
that means that normally when you use
the
references that you have on a qpcr they
tend to saturate the whole system again
the the petitioning error comes into
play
and that means if you uh and i will come
back to that as well
you need to perhaps switch your
reference chains
there are also some otherwise some other
application
on this list but as i said if you just
use your imagination anything you can
extract dna from
anything you can create an essay for you
can do digital pcr on
if we look at lower limits of detection
and this is again
about the sub sampling so this is for
human
so this can be different in different
ways
as i said uh the only thing uh in
digital pcr that's different from a qpcr
is that you normally don't do replicates
but there are
some locations where you actually need
to do that
and that is when you need to lower the
sub sampling area when you load a screen
for something
really really rare and this means that
you need to screen so much dna that you
actually cannot
fit that into one well that means you
need to split your sample
up so as long as for a normal mutation
for instance
with 0.1 percent when you want to find
one in a thousand
of course 100 grams of dna is sufficient
enough and you can use one well
but there are occasions where you let's
say you want to screen one in a thousand
or i mean one in one hundred thousand
and of course you need to gain a lot
more dna let's say up to one microgram
of dna
and then of course you need to actually
do
a split of the sample because it's just
too much to fit into one well
so then you need to split it into four
wells instead
in this case so this is where you start
to do
let's say replicates but of course you
can see these points as
one well in in our software we call that
a hyper one so you can actually just
combine them into
a replicates and the the software will
calculate
as one data point
if we talk about next generation uh
sequencing and digital pcr
so it's this is a very good match
a good marriage if you will because
normally uh
uh next generation sequencing if you use
my sick high sick or iron torrent
or nova seek er normally
you can go down to what let's say one
percent or
point one percent at best it be it
depends on how deep seek
how deep you do your sequencing but man
but of course um when you are down to
let's say
one percent point one percent a normal
qpcr
is not good enough to validate what you
get
if you are within one to five percent
you can use a real-time pcr
that's not a problem because it can
detect down uh down to that
uh have that position it detect it down
to one percent
but of course when you have the acuity
system so digital pcr you can go down to
as i said in the previous slide to
0.1.001
and even further so you're not
limited to how low you can go
as you just heard that how low you can
go
depends on how much dna you have
but due to pcr is also more cost
efficient than next generation
sequencing
sequencing is good when you don't know
how the sequence looks like
and it's very nicely for you to actually
do the sequencing
you get the sequence you then you can
create an essay
and then you use that as a uh
to uh to screen with digital pcr
which can actually detect it to very low
allele frequency or if it's a rare
sequence or
if it's gene expression for instance
if we look about how you can normalize a
sample
input so this is actually
a way of doing that if you let's say in
this example this is human dna
and this is mostly for people that are
working with let's say plasma
you don't want to um
waste your sample because you have
so little samples you don't want to
waste it
so in this case what you can do is
actually just use
what you have totally amplified inside
your wall
so let's say we have a well like this
that we have hundred copies of target a
and then you have a thousand targets of
carpet b
and of course the total amplified
target molecules is actually eleven
hundred
the topless so then you take this
times the reaction volume that we that
we have which is 30 microliters in our
case
then you know that you have 33 copies in
total
and of course if you use that number
times the haploid genome which is 3.3
picograms of dna
then you are up to 108
9 900 picograms which is 108.9 nanograms
so the theoretical um lower limit of
detection
in this case using the rule of three
you know the screen three times many
molecules
you know for the lower limit of
detection then this means
11 11 000 which means in
our case if we have this many uh this
sample input we have one in 11 000
so and this means assuming no false
positives
and of course the false positive rate is
something you need to consider
if you look fermentations and what you
need to do
then is that you need to screen um
your essay with wild types
so you need to screen at least i would
say
a plate with wild types to see if you
have
as an essay specific false positive
rate and this means that these false
positives should come up
randomly in the wild type if they are
just coming in one sample
then this is not a wild type anymore
so if we look at copy number
variation so trading uh
do this in a very simple way because we
are
using um a reference
genome in one well
and we are using that as an equivalent
so we know that our reference has let's
say
20 copies per genome or two copies per
new
genome and then we use that as an
equivalent
to calculate the copy number variation
so if you take example one where you
have
your reference your reference sample has
two copies per genome
and target a has called a thousand
copies per milliliter
as an absolute quantification and target
b has five
thousand copies per milliliter uh of
our reference locus so this corresponds
to a ratio of
uh 0.2 and is equivalent to two copies
per genome because this is the reference
that we have
so this is what we use so target a
in our second example here target a has
1500 copies per microliter and target b
has 5 000 copies
of your reference logos just like the
other one this corresponds to a ratio of
0.3
compared to your known reference sample
which we know has two copies per genome
and 0.2 we just divide them and then we
see
that 0.3 divided by 0.2 times two copies
is actually three copies so this is a
way of using
just one reference for let's say a whole
plate
so this is a little bit different of
course you can
also do it using the absolute
quantification
when you have c and v equals the n
times the concentration of the target
divided the
concentration of the reference using a
probe based approach as well
if we look at gene expression and this
is
where i was referring to you a little
bit before
that if you use your old references and
there has been some
issues um coming forward when you do
this um
because you are you tend to over
saturate the system with your old
reference genes so
when you start a new project with gene
expression so
my suggestion to you is that you run
your two conditions on a qpcr first
with only your reference gene because
then you can pick the one
that are in in the goldilocks zone for
the referencing if you will but
somewhere i would say between 25 to 30.
if you can find a reference gene between
cq or ct of 25 to 30
which is stable in the two conditions
that's the one you can use
in a digital pcr because anything below
21
here on this side down to zero
it's too abundant and will saturate the
whole system for you when it comes to
gene expression
when we talk about um the resolution you
will have
pin expression is outstanding with uh
digital pcr because we talked about
plus minus ten percent until parallel
precision
what does that mean well if you see the
the blue area here in the presentation
that equals
the difference you have in the cq value
with a two-fold dilution in a real-time
pcr
and as you can see if you do a 10
dilution
of your sample with a spike in for
instance like this
you see that you have between you have
many many more data points you have one
two three four
five six seven so up to seven data
points more
than where you actually can distinguish
and see a difference in gene expression
and this is particularly interesting
when we talk about micro rna because you
can see
micro micrornas for biomarker screening
has
started to grow and people tend to want
to see if
there are difference in microrna
expression especially in serum and
plasma
and of course sometimes the difference
is too small for a qpcr to detect
and by looking at it with digital pcr
you are able to actually see
these small differences in a much higher
resolution and they can have
a significant impact on the biological
response
of course when it comes to normal gene
expression in qpcr this
small let's say differences may not be
biola
biologically relevant but hey this is up
to you to decide
but as you can see twofold dilution
inside the
digital pcr compared to a real-time pcr
is quite
high resolution because either you have
100 copies
per microliter or you have about 50 cars
per microliter
so you see the the the it's very high
as you can see you can for sure get a
lot of more data points inside
and this is quite nice to see
so when do you want to do digital pcr
well that is entirely up to
to you i would say no but to be honest
as i mentioned before if you have
recently or previously ran into
issues stopped the project
uh because of two
crude samples um due to
uh extraction problems where you get a
very low
yield um or let's say you cannot perform
a pcr in a good way or a real-time pcr
because the the efficiency has been just
too bad and the data has been looking
well not good enough to present well
now it's the time to take those old
projects and
blow the dust away and take a look at
them again
because we did it to pcr with the
resolution you will have the precision
you will have
and since it's an endpoint measurement
these
tough samples that you have problems
with before will now be able
you will be able now to actually perform
the pcr and perhaps
generate really really good data on this
one
so but it's all what you need to
think about is that you need to be able
to do an
essay and if you don't have that
essay if you don't need there if you
don't have the sequence as i
mentioned before then you need to
actually sequence
the dna to be able to get the sequence
you can create an assay
but of course it's also important
that you have a good extraction method
so and cajun has a variety
of extraction kits for different
and tough samples but this is crucial so
of course you need to first be able to
extract dna or rna so you can actually
either do cdna or
make a library for sequencing
and of course you need to do and be able
to perform an essay
so you can actually create a an essay
and
perform the pcr but as i said
anything you can extract dna from and
create an essay
you can do digital pcr it doesn't matter
if you have crude samples anymore
because of this petitioning
as i have been talking to you about
today
when it comes to primary probe design so
what
what kind of path should i follow and
this is
really important you should always try
to follow the hallmarks of pcr
regardless of
that this is an endpoint pcr so that
means that
you should try to keep the amplicons as
short as possible
anything between 60 to let's say 250
bases
because that's where the efficiency
because you still need efficiency
because you need an application if the
efficiency is zero you have no
amplification and of course
we want the best possible efficiency
the primary probes should be as in the
qpcr so they are 18 to
let's say 25 bases in length and the tm
for the probe should be
uh between 5 to 10 degrees higher than
the primers
so because if the primer binds in before
the probe you have dark pcr and that is
not what we want
and of course the gdc content should be
between 55 to 65 percent uh
for optimal and healing temperature and
three gsos in a row should be avoided
due to fundamental bondings so you know
so we can actually have a good
efficiency and good annealing
and of course if you have very fresh
dna or if you have plasmids or something
that are supercoiled
then of course it will perhaps for
digital pcr
it can be good if you cut the dna
into smaller pieces just to increase the
efficiency and make everything more
efficient
the most important thing is to use a
restriction enzyme that doesn't cut
within the amplicon
so now we have come to the end of this
seminar and i
am done i thank you so much for your
time i hope
that you will have good questions
i hope that you can put them in and then
just for we will answer them as soon as
possible but
it has been a pleasure for me and i need
to add
in these corona times that i give you
all praise to your family and friends
that they are healthy and that you all
are safe thank you so much for me